lundi dernier nous célébrions la journée
des droits des femmes comme chaque 8
mars
l'occasion aussi de mettre l'accent sur
de nombreuses inégalités dont sont
victimes les femmes dans notre société
mais aussi les violences qu'elles
subissent parfois bon partout selon les
chiffres du gouvernement en france le
nombre de femmes victimes de violence
conjugale est estimé à 213 1000 femmes
par an chaque année une femme meurt tous
les quatre jours sous les coups de son
conjoint ce qui représentait l'an
dernier le décès de 90 femmes les
féminicides c'est juste l'aboutissement
ultime de toutes les violences sexistes
et sexuelles et conjugales sujet
important que l'artiste camille
lellouche a décidé de prendre à bras le
corps dans sa dernière chanson intitulée
n'insiste pas elle raconte avec
puissance la violence faite aux femmes
[Musique]
dans la peau d'une victime elle raconte
les coups et l'enfer vécu par ces femmes
une chanson bouleversante qui a été
salué par des milliers d'internautes et
de personnalités et qui compte
aujourd'hui près de 600000 vue camille
lellouche et romane serda sont sur notre
plateau pour nous parler de ce sujet
merci à toutes les deux d'être lakamy
lellouche merci romane serda merci merci
douter d'eux voilà que j'aime beaucoup
les deux plus deux amis je le dis voilà
c'est vrai ton nouveau type de camille
n'insiste pas est un titre très très
engagé franchement c'est vrai que ça a
bouleversé tout le monde ça a été voilà
un déferlement tout le monde en a parlé
et c'est important pour toi d'en parler
tu prévoyait le le titre depuis
longtemps pas tu t'es dit je vais me
sortir le 8 mars et bien tu l'a écrit
comme ça
non le 8 mars est mon ami jean rachid
que tu connais qui est aussi son ami qui
m'a dit sors sans la lulu mars d'accord
quelques mois qu'elle existe et
effectivement naturellement quand ils
messager dubawi tu as raison je rachète
que je connais c'est un de mes meilleurs
amis ni ben oui mais j'ai tout le monde
ne sait pas que son meilleur ami
si toi aussi oui mois ci va falloir
qu'ils choisissent un chouette
voilà alors non mais c'est important
pour toi de dot de parler de ça très
important parce que c'est ça me fait
toujours et quand on dit que ses actuels
ccc là depuis la nuit des temps c'est
juste que là on les langues se délient
puis on en parle un peu plus et c'est
cette chanson n'est pas que pour le 10
mars bien sûr riton qu'on doit écouter
tout c'est comme quand on dit la journée
de la femme c'est pas y aller mais là je
faisais l'ancien journée de la femme le
8 mars à partir d'une haute marche petit
connard non non non voilà donc c'est
vrai que c'est important dans les
paroles elles sont très dures c'était
volontaire ou pas ta part tu es parce
qu'on m'a posé la question l'interview
et on dit ouais tu dis quand même à
casser la gueule magie du web tu vas
dire quoi d'autre ben quand on se casse
la gueule on casse la gueule que moi
c'est mes mots je suis un langage très
simple j'essaie d'interpréter au mieux
mais quand on casse la gueule on casse
la gueule quoi une fois notre taf et
cite aussi camille pour que et les
femmes qui qui se reconnaissent dans ses
paroles dures et kehl pour les pousser à
témoigner pour les pousser à parler
aussi
moi je pousse personne à faire quoi que
ce soit c'est chaque histoire est
différente
je connais bien le sujet
ça arrivait à pas mal de proches c'est
vrai que toutes ces histoires sont
différentes
après on ne peut pas dire à quelqu'un
d'à porter plainte fais comme tu peux
déjà pour te sentir bien et en sortir
après évidemment c'est un message quand
ces femmes-là qui s'en sont sortis je
reçois énormément énormément de messages
a dû recevoir énormément de bayssan
armements déjà qu'avant ça dans cette
chanson quand ceux des interviews sur
sur ce sujet dramatique on me disait tu
en parles hyper bien ses pairs juste moi
j'ai vécu ça j'ai réussi à m'en sortir
et puis en ce moment il ya des femmes
qui m'envoient des messages et qui me
disent je suis encore dedans c'est
horrible comment faire mais moi je leur
réponds fait comme vous pouvez me faites
attention à vous je suis personne pour
dire aller porter plainte même si ce
serait la meilleure chose à faire
évidemment c'est tellement violent et
c'est tellement dans un engrenage était
avec un bourreau qui te met plus bas que
terre et à ce moment là les gens ne
peuvent pas comprendre tour c'est très
très très violent c'est à dire que on
quand on te dit tu es une merde tu y
crois parce que tu es lobotomisés est en
permanence on te dit tu es comme ça tu
fais ça je t'aime plus que tout le monde
autour et souvent ça rime à des femmes
très très forte et leur but c'est
justement de te mettre plus bas que
terre et et quand on arrive la remontée
ces longs ont déjà une rupture classique
c'est très très long oui j'ai déjà quand
et avec quelqu'un en relation de dire ok
je sais je vais le quitter mais quand
c'est dur mais quelqu'un que tu aimes
mais qui te tapes tu dois le quitter
alors que tu l'aies mais en plus ils te
tape donc tu as peur pour la suite c'est
c'est très très complète pour les gens
les abrutis 10ème et pourquoi tu pars
pas mais connard tu n'es pas dans cette
situation
tu ne peux pas savoir donc donc moi je
suis là pour ces femmes tous les jours
et voilà jusqu alors justement il ya
romane qui la romaine que j'adore le
sait romane serda à la vie à l'amour sa
trajectoire de femme et d'artiste merci
romane d'être là romain intervenus
survenus dernièrement sur les violences
conjugales dont il a été victime tôt si
par le passé enfin parce que tu peux
nous raconter ce qui sait ce qui s'est
passé c'est qu'on déjà alors j'ai pas je
ne situe pas la chose dans le temps
parce que par rapport aux mecs j'ai pas
envie qu'on cite l'accord ok c'est un
connard les ja c'est un vrai connard
donc dans mon livre j'en parle mais
c'est pareil j'en parle à l'âge de 20
ans dans la chronologie et je dis que ça
m'arrivera plus tard donc voila quand
donc tu dirais pas voilà tu veux pas
qu'on roman d'accord on a compris ce
n'est pas tant monde a compris tu veux
pas savoir qui ne regroupe pas qu'on
sache qui sait et a raison mais même si
j'ai bien envie de gâcher ce moment de
merde
et pourquoi vous le faites pas du coup
même si c'est très intime et très
personnelle à ce même ce serait de la
vengeance
lui c'est quoi tu vois d'accord fille ça
sert à rien je fais pas une guerre
personnelle
moi je suis là ce soir je me disais mais
je suis pas la porte parole qu'est ce
que j'ai à faire là et puis en fait je
me dis non je vais venir parce que j'ai
pas envie de fermer ma gueule parce que
ça arrive à plein de gens parce que j'ai
plein de copines autour de moi comme tu
utilises et camille aussi qui sont
victimes de sa qui sont souvent aussi
des d'ailleurs des personnalités un peu
atypique qui sont qui sont brillantes
est qui et qui se font quand même
bouffer par ces mecs là qui ont qui ont
trop de gentillesse qui entre aude
d'empathie qui qui serait ce qu'ils sont
dépassés par ce que tu peux nous
raconter son histoire
en fait c'est le jour où je décide de
quitter ce fameux connard à on va bien
monsieur connard l'on appelait colère
mais en plus il est il est appelé comme
ça pour tout on l'appelle comme ça ça
d'accord mais que voilà qu'on tue dix
connards dans la rue ce retour ne sait
qui se fait appeler comme ça d'accord
et donc je décide de le quitter il est
minuit je dormais et puis et puis en
fait ça s'est mal passé suite à tunis il
s'était formé quand même au dessus il
n'y avait rien n'y avait rien lu avant
aucune violence avant si une fois une
violence jeunes avaient attrapé par les
cheveux
il m'avait plaqué sur le leem a effectué
des claques d'accord il apte à laisser
passer ça tu habites est passée en dix
ans parce que moi je me dis toujours bon
il va comprendre c'est impossible enfin
pourquoi est ce qui est à dire prêt pour
pourvoir et devient un enjeu il devient
un jeu voilà qu'est ce que je suis
désolé je voulais vraiment pas de faire
mal je suis rejetait pas fait mal et
tout puis moi c'est assez rester je me
dis bon que tu sois tu as dis que c'est
possible et ça je laissais passer en en
me disant je lui donne une autre chance
donc là il est minuit comme mai à minuit
tu détiens dans ma 00h tu décides de le
quitter comme ça et donc non la deuxième
fois ouais je
non je ne décide pas comme ça c'est que
le mec il était c'était un pm c'est un
pervers narcissique le mec c'était un
mec qui me manipulait qui était
humiliant qui était moi je suis tombé
dans le schéma de ce genre de personnage
plusieurs fois d'accord parce que j'ai
une personnalité qui est un petit peu
atypique et on pourra développer ça dans
un autre truc si tu veux mais je laisse
un petit peu passé ça et je me dis que
ce serait trop injuste que que le mec ne
comprennent pas à quoi donc jeu j'essaye
de de lui dire les choses il comprend
pas et ça se passe en fait le mec il
n'arrive pas à s'exprimer ou je ne sais
pas et et il me fait tomber je m'étais
fait opérer des deux pieds j'avais deux
pieds je pouvais je ne pouvais pas
marcher j'étais vraiment en même temps
les deux pieds et du coup il m'a poussé
m'a mis par terre et il m'a bastonné par
dessus mais c'était terrifiant quoi
terrifiant tu étais vraiment vraiment
vraiment un moment je sentais plus tu
sais la force des coups dans la gueule
tu sens plus dire que tu deviens elle
choque croyable ouais incroyable et donc
qu'est-ce qui après qu'est ce qui se
passe à une prudente un étage et c'est
dans quel état après je suis comme dans
les pommes je sais pas si j'ai perdu
conscience
il est c'est-à-dire heatley ce nom et me
laisse comme ça après j'essaye de me
relever mais je peux pas donc je rentre
et je rattrape le téléphone pour appeler
les flics ils étaient toujours là il
était toujours il était en train de
partir et il me rattrape le téléphone
j'avais filmé il ouvre le poids lever un
poêle à bois chez moi il le fou dans le
poêle à bois ni téléphone et ils cassent
la poignée du poêle à bois quand même le
mec il ne force il était déchaîné quoi
et puis j'avais un chat et le chat il
regardait comme ça puis miaulait et je
me disais [ __ ] mais c'est quelque
chose du chat s'écrit avec votre fils
toi la tête a dit que j'étais là vous
aviez votre fils dans la et dormait au
dessus ils ont ils bien longtemps du hip
hop un nom il était minuit dormait
c'était dans son premier mari la pente
heureusement limites sociales non mais
c'est vrai qu'ils aient donc après
qu'est-ce qui se passe après vous leurs
voiliers ou bien c'était terminé si la
gale info vous l'avez vu vous avez porté
plainte derrière
moi j'ai porté plainte il a été jugé ça
a pris du temps il a été jugé il a et il
a eu deux mille euros de d'amande et
puis évidemment tout le monde à elles
trois ans avec sursis
j'avais eu des nouvelles depuis enfin
après ouais ouais ouais ouais ce qui
vous met crime et moi je réponds jamais
quoi il m'écrit mais j'écris il ya deux
mois maintenant je souhaite à partager
cette bonne nouvelle avec toi j'ai
répondu que j'en ai à [ __ ]
non je réponds même pas bah oui en fou
peut-être bloqué numéro peut-être moi je
vais bloqués non mais c'est s'est séparé
en plus qui se connaît ma voisine enfin
bon mec c'est un vrai connard vrai de
vrai [ __ ] comment tu t'en es sorti
commente a été traumatisée par cette
forcément pas en fait je sois dans la
résilience je pense que je dépasse les
trucs que je me dis ouais je pense que
j'apprends de tout tu vois c'est une
épreuve et je me dis ok je je vivrai
plus à quoi
en fait c'est tout ce que j'ai besoin
d'aller vraiment fond du truc pour pour
moore tous ces bienfaits réussi à trop
construire derrière avec les hommes
c'est tenir avec nous avec la print et
l'expérience web très vite ou non pas
très vite je passais très longtemps je
vais pas du coup je vais pas dire
combien mes dupeux a fait pas mal de
temps à apa moi être seule
ouais tu arrivais pas ouais tu pouvais
plus faire confiance aux hommes ouais
mais je j'ai re la confiance ça revient
à mais aujourd'hui pas je vais super
bien oui tu le sais bah oui oui c'est
vrai il a mis un romano là c'est que là
je la donne est ce que pour les deux
c'est dans l'action pourrait vous poser
un jour elle a posé à vous deux est ce
que vous trouvez vous fait assez pour
les violences conjugales là vous nous
avez dit voilà 2000 euros 3 ans avec
sursis
c'est parce qu'on trouvait qu'on fasse
esquisse aimeriez qu'on fasse plus
forcément camille à pardon mais c'est du
foutage de gueule ça je me permets de
2001 dans les mines marchait déjà mais
qu'ils pouvaient me tuer fall était
vraiment pas loin de faire son quant à
quoi s'était et 2000 euros bon ben voila
quoi puis surtout je pense que j'en
parlais aussi en interview récemment
mais je pense que
il faut écouter vraiment sincèrement
souvent elles vont les femmes qui osent
et qui arrive à aller porter plainte on
leur dit enfin on épand n'est pas sûr on
dit ouais mais c'est bon vous êtes déjà
venu après vous êtes revenu sur votre
fils qui est le plus qui est le plus
grave est excuse moi un camille sée qu'
il ya beaucoup de femmes aussi qu'ils
disent je vais pas aller porter plainte
parce que j'ai peur qu'on mette ma
parole en doute ou si c'est ça
voilà voilà il ya un autre truc c'est
que moi j'ai mis des semaines a porté
plainte oui parce que je suis beck le
mât qui viennent me refrapper quoi rêver
d'un mois qu'est-ce que tu le maquiller
parce que quand tu portes plainte il est
à plat tout de suite et il sait où
j'habite paris
tu vois je suis très content d'ailleurs
il faudrait savoir où il est je suis à
vandaliser super u a donc porté plainte
j'étais la bomba non enfin j'ai mis du
temps à me dire ok je m'en fous je le
fais quoi